this small crocodile has been kept as a
pet for the past three years and has
clearly grown used to its creature
comforts this is from a lot of chicken
keeping a crocodile in your garden pond
is illegal in Belize reptiles that have
been confiscated by the authorities are
put into the care of Marisa Tess and her
NGO crocodile research coalition 66
points when I tell people I study
crocodiles what comes to mind are
dangerous pass
vermin man-eaters monsters and all this
stems from dramatization that you see in
TV as well as the media for Marisa
taya's and her fellow conservationists
every crocodile deserves protection with
the help of a local vet she gives this
Mora lays crocodile a check-up before
taking the specimen to its new home
Tia's originally from the US has been
fascinated by large predators since she
was a child her doctoral thesis focused
on crocodiles today and she's
effectively Belize's chief lobbyist for
the reptiles it's a normal day driving
throughout the country with the
crocodile in the back seat
whether this crocodile will ever be fit
for reintroduction to the wild still
remains to be seen
crocodiles are part of life in the
rivers and lagoons of bellies but most
people want as little contact as
possible with them not surprising given
the largely negative headlines
I'm not harmed by crocodiles because I
love my feet on my hand so that's going
to matter and they could bite off your
feet and eat that so they are very
dangerous they are deadly animals but
peaceful coexistence with the animals is
possible as Marissa tears is eager to
communicate whenever she can today she's
bringing that message to a podcast
protecting one species the world think
it's dangerous in its trunk dance nard
mission is to assist in educate about
the protection and conservation of
crocodiles and their habitats and when
she's not out fighting for greater
awareness she dedicates herself to
individual crocodiles in need of help
the coalition's small team also get
outside support among their partners is
the National Zoo
the vets here suited those animals that
require intensive medical treatment
one of them more acute cases is a tragic
one evidently somebody tried to chop
this crocodiles tail off for some people
in bellies a delicacy Luc was able to
escape with his tail half 7 he was found
by chance by the crocodile research
coalition while out on an excursion how
Luc escaped from someone chopping at his
tail we will never know but he has an
important story to tell the tale has yet
to grow back together properly if the
events decide they have to amputate
Luc will remain in the zoo as a warning
that crocodile hunting has to stop and
illegal hunting is far from the only
danger faced by crocodiles urban
expansion is also a problem in many
areas the new river near the town of
orange walk in the north of the country
has become toxic and indeed lethal for
the reptiles there is something in the
water that has been causing a high rate
of deaths of crocodiles and when you
conducted the necropsy everything inside
them had turned to mush these crocodiles
have been slowly dying for months what's
killing them is probably wastewater
discharged by the sugarcane factories
lining the river
Marissa taya's and her team head out to
check on the crocodile populations
health at night when they're active
some baby crocs are small enough to be
plucked out of the water by hand
the examinations only take five minutes
long enough for the specimen to have
various measurements and samples taken
and its skin analyzed this young animal
at least seems to be in great health but
will it remain the case in addition to
Mora lays crocodiles bellies is also
home to a second species the far larger
American crocodile across the country
both species live in an increasingly
restricted and polluted habitat so
currently both species are protected by
law however there is no conservation and
management action plan so all this data
that we are collecting it is to help
government to then create the most
appropriate action plan tonight's
expedition is not a very fruitful one
the team haven't spotted many crocodiles
[Music]
another day another task
Marrissa taya's is visiting one of the
larger crocodiles being tended to by her
organization Gilly also used to be kept
as a pet and is now too tamed to ever be
returned to the wild stay good stay
ghillie Marisa uses a few basic commands
for the purposes of training and gaining
Gilley's respect target there we go good
target
even if Gilly seems relatively harmless
Marisa says crocodiles belong in the
wild and many of the specimens she sees
need help to survive there this is where
education is so important because
education provides the knowledge the
knowledge to be able to coexist with
these animals because we can coexist
with these animals indigenous cultures
have been coexisting with these
animals for thousands and thousands of
years